things aren't looking too good for you
mal a huge betrayal is on its way and
Oona was probably right someone you put
your trust in doesn't want you becoming
the queen of auradon so hold on to your
crown while you still can because a
great evil is coming for it but if Hades
is really your dad you're literally the
strongest BK in Disney history so we're
sure you'll figure it all out it's
official guys Disney's descendants is
hitting the small screen on August 2nd
if you're as excited as we are you might
have missed some key moments in the new
descendants 3 trailer but don't worry
we've got you covered if there's one
thing we couldn't help but notice its
Mouse hair and no we're not talking
about how awesome it looks we're talking
about its mysterious color change when
we first see mal in the trailer her hair
is as purple as Bernie himself but once
she meets Hades it starts turning blue
we see it transforming when Ben
announces justice souter in the Queen's
crown of install and by the time mal is
leaning over audrey sleeping body it's
as blue as Edie's this sudden
transformation has to account for
something right
another thing we noticed is that mal and
uma seem to be on better terms
throughout the trailer during the new
trailer we hear mal telling Emma that
people's lives are endangered this is a
job for pirate this is a job for pirates
but what exactly is she referring to the
only job a pirate really has is locating
lost treasure or stealing across the sea
and seeing as mal is still on the Isle
she may need a ride back to Oregon
either way the trailer gives us hope
that Malin uma will bury the hatchet the
trailer is loaded with clues
unfortunately they flash before our eyes
so quickly that it's easy to miss them
one thing we didn't miss is Audrey's
crime and motive when Ben proposes to
mal Audrey shrieked so loudly she
shocked the entire crowd if you pay
close attention to her hands you'll see
that she has pink nails and plenty of
rings and later on we see this exact
hand reaching out for the stolen crown
it's clear that if Audrey can't be queen
of auradon
nobody can least of all mal we were
seriously rooting for Celia facili a but
no one was rooting for her as much as
mal after all she
allegedly chose Celia to be her BK
recruit but in this new trailer we see
Celia throw Katie's Ember into a bucket
of water the amber goes up in smoke and
mal cries out in protest even uma looks
a little surprised by Celia's actions
right after this we see Celia laughing
evilly with her tarot cards in hand does
this mean that Celia doesn't want mal to
rescue her friends it sure looks that
way during the end of the trailer we see
Hades blasting his ember at the BK's
Evie and mal don't get hit by the blast
but Ben Carlos and Jay are thrown back
by it could the amber have placed a
curse on them this could explain why we
later see Ben turning into a beast when
Celia destroys the Ember did Ben's
instant anger caused him to transform
into the worst version of himself who
knew that turning into a beast could be
genetic we know that Ben likes to give
mal gifts he gave her a purple scooter
in descendants - and now it looks like
he's taken things a step further not
only do we see King van proposing de mal
at the beginning of the trailer but we
also see the V case driving around in a
purple limousine if you look at the
license plate you'll see mouths name
strewn across it looks like riding into
the Isle of the Lost with a personalized
limo was a bad decision thanks to the
trailer we now know that someone used
Maleficent scepter to cast a curse while
at auradon we actually see the curse
being cast but it's hard to recognize
who the culprit is due to them wearing a
black lace overcoat
still we have reason to believe that
it's Audrey and it looks like Audrey
cast the spell from her auradon prep
private balcony on a side note it looks
like Carlos's girlfriend Jane is going
to play a major role in the third
descendants film this makes sense
considering her very own mother gets
turned to stone we see Jane slowly
submerging herself into the enchanted
lake is Jean looking for a possible cure
the enchanted Lake did get rid of Ben's
love spell so maybe something in the
lake can put an end to or Don's new
stone people population we also noticed
that Oregon isn't the only Society
that's under attack
it looks like the vks are being targeted
as well when mal tells Emma that
people's lives are in danger we see
the V case from the Isle of the lost
backing away with terrified expressions
on their faces it's clear that they had
no idea that Hades was going to attack
the king of auradon and his friends but
the most shocking clue of all is that
mal is going to do something awful to
win the war at the end of the trailer we
see a dark cloud of purple magic smoke
enveloping mouths body her eyes turn
green and she transforms into her dragon
self she spits fire at a building and
this is when we hear Mao screaming I had
no choice now obviously feels
responsible for her friends turning to
stone but what did she do exactly did
you guys notice anything we miss sound
off in the comments section below and
leave a crumb emoji in the comments if
you're counting down the days to August
2nd thanks for watching the things give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button
we'll see you soon
[Music]